دكتور نحن نقدر لك الوقت الذي تقضيه
للانضمام إلينا ، فنحن نعلم مدى صعوبة هذا
الوضع ، هل يمكنك أن تعطينا فكرة
هذا الصباح عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذه المنطقة
من سوريا ، حيث تم إغلاق العديد من
المستشفيات العامة التي تم إغلاق العيادات الصحية فيها
أو في أحسن الأحوال تعمل جزئيًا من قبل
إلى هذا الزلزال المدمر ،
ما الذي تحتاجه هذا الصباح ،
مرحباً أندرو ، شكراً جزيلاً لك
قدم لي ، والمستشفى في شمال
سوريا يعمل بكامل طاقته ولكن
هذا ضخم جدًا وهو أكثر من
قدرتنا على علاج النقاد في
شمال سوريا الذين يحاولون.  لعلاج المرضى
وفقط أه نعم ليس لدينا ما
يكفي من المعدات والأدوية ولم يكن
لدى مستشفانا القدرة على
استقبال العدد الهائل من المرضى
والجرحى أه المستشفى السوري في شمال
سوريا يحتاج الآن إلى كل ما يحتاجه
الفريق المحترف  تعال وتساعد
في مستشفى شمال سوريا ، فهي تحتاج
أيضًا إلى مستهلكات دوائية وتحتاج
أيضًا إلى إنتاج فرق الإنتاج على فرق موسيقية لتأتي
وإنقاذ الأشخاص الذين يعيشون تحت المنازل
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص ما زالوا
تحت سيطرة المتمردين ولا نعرف
عدد الأشخاص في هذه العائلة معظم
الملائكة الذين يأتون إلى المستشفى هم من
الأطفال والنساء وكبار السن
الذين تكون إصاباتهم شديدة
ولا يمكننا التعامل معهم بشكل جيد دون
بذل قصارى جهدنا ولكن الضخم أكبر
من قدرتنا على الإعجاب  للتعامل مع
أتساءل دكتور حاتم بالنظر إلى كل
القتال الدائر هناك في شمال سوريا لديك
أه الحكومة السورية لديك
قوات روسية لديك قوات متمردة هي
المعونة قادرة على تجاوز كل ذلك إلى
حيث هو مطلوب على الإطلاق
ليس لأنه  تعلمون
أن المتحف بأكمله استمر لأكثر
من عقود وأن قدرة
المستشفيات والمسعفين ضعيفة
ولا يمكنهم التعامل بسبب بحيرة
الأدوية والمستشفيات منشأة صحية عاطلة عن العمل
في أستراليا في
السنوات القليلة الماضية أه المستشفيات
لا يوجد ما يكفي لعلاج
العدد الهائل من الأشخاص والأشخاص
الذين يأتون الآن إلى مستشفانا بسبب
الزلزال اللورد ،
إنه وضع مؤلم للغاية ومن
المهم جدًا أن نستمر في الاستماع
إلى أشخاص مثلك دكتور حاتم إلى  تعرف على
ما هو مطلوب على الأرض خاصة
فيما يتعلق بالحصول على المساعدة التي من خلالها ، كما
أوضحت جيم ، أكره هذا السؤال في غاية
الأهمية ، إنه طبيب صعب للغاية ،
شكرًا لك على وقتك وعلى كل
العمل الذي كنت تقوم به